I just love this place, don’t you?
I know it’s kinda expensive, but everything’s
so top notch!
Hey folks. Know what you want?
Yes!
I’d like to eat the Down Payment on a House,
with a side of flambeed Emergency Fund.
Excellent choice.
And for you, sir?
I’m pretty hungry, so I’m gonna have Our
Retirement Savings, and... what the heck,
a bottle of Our Daughter’s College Tuition.
Very good.
Do you think we spend too much dining out?
Maybe… but everyone else is doing it.
Besides, what’s the alternative?
Cooking at home?
At least the breadsticks are free.
21% of Americans have no retirement savings,
and another 10% have less than $5,000.
It’s even bleaker for millennials: nearly
6 in 10 have nothing saved at all.
Now, there are a lot of reasons for this:
the increasing cost of housing, health insurance,
and of course, student debt.
But for many people, those costs are relatively
fixed.
If you’re looking for practical areas to
cut back, one sticks out like a fly in your
soup: DINING OUT.
In 2015, for the first time in history, Americans
spent more money on bars and restaurants than
on groceries, with the average household now
spending more than $3,000 annually on “food
away from home,” representing between 5
and 7 percent of their total spending.
Even though restaurant prices are increasing
faster than inflation, and grocery prices
are holding steady--or even falling!--the
average diner is still eating out around 5
times a week.
How much is this costing us?
Well, restaurants typically mark up their
food by around 300%, meaning the price on
the menu is about 3 times what they actually
spent on the food.
If that seems like a lot, remember, you’re
also paying for the restaurant’s rent, labor,
equipment and overhead.
So if you live in an area where real estate
values are increasing, that also applies to
the surface area of your local restaurant’s
tabletops.
And that doesn’t even include drinks!
A survey by Zagat found that the average restaurant
bill per person is over $36.
If you do this just 3 times a week, that’s
over $5,600 a year!
By contrast, the average meal cooked at home
with groceries from the market is about $4
per person.
Now you can see why so many financial advisors
focus on dining out as a place to save money.
How much money could you potentially save?
I think it’s time to….
Run the Numbers!
Let’s say Jake here goes out for dinner
3 times a week, spending $35 each time.
He starts every workday with a latte and croissant
at his local coffee shop and buys lunch
at the local food court 4 days a week
(Fridays are pizza day at the office).
In one year, he’s spent over $9,000 on commercially
prepared food and drinks--over 12% of his
yearly salary of $75,000.
What if Jake could get those 3 dinners down
to just one a week?
And what if he started making coffee and breakfast
at home, and brown-bagged lunches at work?
Assuming that all those homemade meals would
come out to around $5 each, that would mean
a yearly savings of $4,420!
That’s enough for a Hawaiian vacation!
But wait, we’re not done!
What if Jake took those yearly savings and
put them into an account earning 7% compound
interest?
In just 10 years, he’d have over $65,000.
Enough for a down payment on a house!
In 20 years, he’d have almost $200,000!
All from just eating at home more often.
Jake’s example demonstrates that even in
an era of burdensome healthcare and student
loan obligations, you might have some wiggle-room
in your finances.
Even a small cutback in dining out could allow
you to finally pay off an onerous debt or
build an emergency fund.
This might be easy advice to give, but harder
to put into practice.
Many of us dine out because we’re too busy
or tired to cook after a long day of work.
(if we know how to cook at all).
And going to restaurants isn’t just about
the food.
It’s a social event--a place to see your
friends, to connect with co-workers, to take
the edge off a stressful day.
So we’re not saying “never go out to eat!”
But if you want to cut down on this expense,
you first have to know WHY you’re spending
the money in the first place.
Is it a CONVENIENCE or a LUXURY?
If it’s a CONVENIENCE--in other words, if
you’re eating out because you don’t have
time to cook at home, well, the problem might
just be a lack of preparation.
After all, brewing a pot of coffee and toasting
a bagel can be less time-consuming than waiting
in a Starbucks line.
And can potentially save you hundreds of
dollars.
There are lots of resources on the web for
how to make shopping and cooking cheap and
simple - including this video we made about
navigating the supermarket - but if you’re
still intimidated by the prospect, you could
ease yourself into it by utilizing ingredient-or-grocery
delivery services like Blue Apron or Instacart.
These are definitely more expensive than doing
your own shopping, but still cheaper than
eating out.
We like to use cash at the supermarket to
stay within a budget, but if you’re trying
to incentivize yourself, you could look into
a credit card that gives rewards for grocery
purchases.
And it’s always a good idea to keep some
convenience foods like microwavable dinners
in your freezer.
That way, on days that you really don’t
feel like cooking, you’ll have an alternative
to stopping for take-out or ordering in.
On the other hand, if eating out is a LUXURY--that
is, if you’re doing it for social or psychological
needs--there still might be ways to achieve
that with less spending.
For instance, you can share an entree.
Restaurant portions are typically much larger
than the average diner’s appetite, because
it makes it easier for businesses to justify
high prices.
If you’re there for the service and the
atmosphere, you can get that without overeating
to the point of discomfort or leaving uneaten
food behind.
If you have favorite restaurants you know
you visit often, it might be a good idea to
sign up for their email lists or check Groupon
for details.
But beware that these “bargains” are intended
to make you visit more frequently.
Same goes for “diner’s reward cards”.
If you’re not careful, these strategies
might actually increase your monthly dining
expenses.
Alcohol is one of the biggest markups for
restaurants, so if you like to have a drink
with dinner, you might want to find places
that allow you to BYOB.
Similarly, going to an ice cream shop after
dinner is usually much cheaper than ordering
dessert at the table.
And lastly, if you find yourself buying lunch
just as an excuse to get out of the office,
no one’s forcing you to eat at your desk!
(Hopefully.)
Take your brown bag to a nearby park or public
space.
It’s the same psychological benefit without
the cost.
Dining out is a big part of our culture, and
it might be an important aspect of your social
or professional life, so we’re not suggesting
you cut it out cold turkey.
But you shouldn’t accept any large, regular
expense without asking yourself three fundamental
questions: How much am I spending on this?
What do I get out of it?
Can I get the same benefit for less money?
And that’s our two cents!
Do you have any tips on how to save money while dining out?
Go ahead and share them with us in the comments!